we may be one step closer to renaming
mccarran airport some
faa flight maps now labeled with harry
reid international airport
the new name approved by clark county
commissioners earlier this year
is in honor of the longtime u.s senator
from nevada but signs at the airport
still say mccarran orc omana joins us
live to explain why orco
well brian the name change to harry reid
international
is not 100 percent official but i'm told
it's pretty much a done deal
that means signs like this one here at
the airport will likely
no longer say mccarran
it's just very exciting signs at
mccarran airport will likely say harry
reid international after the clark
county commission unanimously voted for
the change in february
some faa documents have already switched
to the new name but the airport tells us
no formal notification has been sent out
yet because it looks like they've
somewhere down in the bureaucracy
they've approved it
but i knew that actually hasn't
officially happened yet
clark county commissioner tick
sagerbloom a longtime advocate for the
name change says the letter from the faa
is more of a formality
he says changing the signage will cost
about 4 million dollars and it's all
through private donations not
taxpayer money we had one person donate
a million dollars
we have another couple that hopefully be
about a million then we just have to
raise the
million some do not want to name the
airport after the democratic senator and
have something else in mind
i think the name is las vegas everybody
knows
what is las vegas so las vegas airport
it's easier for the tourists
everybody around the world knows
las vegas so las vegas is more
easy but sega bloom says harry reid
international is a done deal
it's going to happen his main goal to
honor senator reed i think he's the most
important nevada never
but to also have him see us honor him
now because the faa has not officially
approved the new name yet
the timeline for changing these signs is
still unclear but sega bloom tells me he
hopes to have
a ceremony here at the airport with
senator reid
by the end of the summer reporting live
in las vegas tonight orco mana 8 news
now